the easiest question that I like to ask
when we're analyzing one of the
businesses that we're thinking about
purchasing is there a way that we can
get someone to buy this and never stop
paying for it is there a way that we can
make this so good that the moment their
card changes or they get a new credit
card they call us ahead of time because
they don't want to stop receiving value
if your phone gets changed your phone
carrier and your credit card goes out
what do you do you call your phone card
you replace it because the value is
there if your credit card goes out what
do you call Netflix you're gonna make
sure that your car goes through if your
utilities go out because your car
doesn't go through you [ __ ] pay if
your rent doesn't go through you make
sure that it's paid on time because
these are things that are valuables that
you cannot live without the goal is to
figure out a way to make our value so
high that people don't want to stop
paying you want to be in the reorder not
the order business